ברוכים הבאים חזרה להבנת מידע קוונטי וחישוב, שמי John Watrous ואני המנהל הטכני לחינוך ב-IBM
Quantum. זהו השיעור העשירי בסדרה והשיעור השני ביחידה השלישית שעוסקת בניסוח
הכללי של מידע קוונטי. השיעור הזה עוסק בערוצים שמייצגים שינויים במערכות
שמאחסנות מידע קוונטי. זה כולל פעולות שימושיות כמו אלו שמבוצעות על ידי
gate-ים יוניטריים ו-circuit-ים קוונטיים, וגם שינויים שהיינו מעדיפים להימנע מהם כמו רעש. אפשר גם לתאר מדידות
כערוצים וזה משהו שניכנס אליו בשיעור הבא. המונח ערוץ מגיע אלינו מתורת
המידע, שבין היתר חוקרת את קיבולת העברת המידע של ערוצי תקשורת
רועשים. אז כשאנחנו חושבים על ערוצים אנחנו חושבים באופן מופשט על ערוצי
תקשורת. אולי זה נראה קצת מוזר לחשוב על חישוב מורכב כערוץ תקשורת, אבל אנחנו צריכים
מילה להתייחס למושג הכללי של תהליך שמשנה מידע בצורה כלשהי, ולטוב או לרע המילה
ערוץ נתקעה, בלי ספק בזכות ההשפעה העצומה שלתורת המידע ובפרט לעבודתו של
Claude Shannon בשנות ה-40 הייתה על מידע קוונטי וחישוב. הנה סקירה של
השיעור. נתחיל עם הבסיס כולל ההגדרה של מה זה ערוץ וגם איך פעולות יוניטריות בניסוח המפושט
של מידע קוונטי יכולות להיות מתוארות כערוצים. נדבר גם על העובדה שצירופים קמורים של ערוצים הם ערוצים, ואם אתם
תוהים למה המושג הזה של קמירות ממשיך לצוץ, זה בגלל שזהו באמת מושג מתמטי חשוב ביותר בתורת
המידע הקוונטי. נראה גם כמה דוגמאות של ערוצים, ספציפית ערוצי qubit שיופיעו מחדש מדי פעם
לאורך שארית השיעור. בחלק השני של השיעור נדבר על שלוש דרכים שונות שבהן אפשר לייצג ערוצים
מתמטית, ובפרט נדבר על ייצוגי Stinespring, ייצוגי Kraus וייצוגי Choi
שנקראים על שם שלושה אנשים שעבודתם הייתה חשובה בפיתוח הייצוגים השונים האלה. ובחלק השלישי
והאחרון של השיעור נדון בהוכחה מתמטית שקובעת ששלושת הייצוגים האלה הם למעשה שקולים, וגם בעובדה שהם
כולם מאפיינים נכונה את ההגדרה של מה זה ערוץ. זו הוכחה מתמטית ממש מגניבה לדעתי ובתקווה שהיא תוסיף
בהירות לייצוגים השונים האלה, איך הם קשורים ואיך הם עובדים באופן כללי. נתחיל עם הבסיס
ונתייחס לשאלה מה הם ערוצים. כפי שכבר רמזתי בתחילת השיעור, ערוצים מתארים שינויים,
ספציפית שינויים בדידים בזמן במערכות שמאחסנות מידע קוונטי. כאן כשאנחנו מתייחסים לשינוי בדיד
בזמן אנחנו פשוט חושבים על שינוי שמתרחש בין שני רגעים נפרדים בזמן, בניגוד לתהליך
רציף למשל שהגיוני לחשוב עליו על פני תקופות זמן קטנות אינסופית. ערוצים כוללים פעולות שימושיות כמו
פעולות יוניטריות שמבוצעות על ידי gate-ים ו-circuit-ים קוונטיים, וגם שינויים כתוצאה מרעש למשל.
אבל לצורכי השיעור הזה בעיקר נחשוב על ערוצים במונחים מתמטיים מופשטים ולא יהיה צורך מיוחד
להבחין בין מה שימושי למה שלא. שמות טיפוסיים לערוצים כוללים את האותיות היווניות הגדולות פי,
פסי וקסי, ונשתמש באותיות שונות להתייחס לכמה ערוצים ספציפיים. במצב פשוט שבו
יש לנו מערכת שנמצאת במצב שמתואר על ידי מטריצת צפיפות רו ומפעילים ערוץ פי על המערכת,
התוצאה היא מערכת שמצבה מתואר על ידי מטריצת הצפיפות פי של רו. אז אנחנו חושבים על ערוץ
נתון פי כפונקציה שאפשר להפעיל על מטריצות צפיפות בגודל מסוים, או במילים אחרות
מטריצות צפיפות של מערכת מסוימת שעליה אנחנו מפעילים את הערוץ. יש כמה דרישות שערוצים חייבים לקיים כדי להיחשב
ערוצים תקפים. ראשית, ערוצים הם העתקות לינאריות. זה לגמרי אנלוגי למצב שיש לנו הן
בניסוח המפושט של מידע קוונטי שבו פעולות על וקטורי מצב קוונטיים הן בהכרח לינאריות,
וגם בניסוח הסטנדרטי של מידע קלאסי שבו פעולות הסתברותיות הן לינאריות. אפשר לבחור לערער על הדרישה
הבסיסית הזו של לינאריות אם ממש רוצים, אבל אם אנחנו רוצים תאוריה שעקבית גם עם תורת ההסתברות
וגם עם הבחירה לייצג מצבים קוונטיים עם מטריצות צפיפות, אז אין לנו באמת ברירה ואנחנו פשוט צריכים לקבל שערוצים הם לינאריים.
הדרישה השנייה היא שערוצים ממירים מטריצות צפיפות למטריצות צפיפות. זה הגיוני לגמרי כי אם בחרנו לייצג
מצבים של מערכות עם מטריצות צפיפות ומפעילים ערוץ על מערכת שנמצאת במצב כלשהו, אז התוצאה חייבת להיות מצב תקף ולכן
מיוצגת על ידי מטריצת צפיפות. יש נקודה מאוד חשובה להוסיף כאן, והיא שהדרישה הזו
צריכה להתקיים לא רק אם מפעילים ערוץ על מערכת מבודדת שמצבה מתואר על ידי מטריצת צפיפות,
אלא גם אם יש לנו מערכת מורכבת שמצבה מתואר על ידי מטריצת צפיפות כלשהי ומפעילים את הערוץ רק על
חלק מהמערכת. אז אלו הדרישות שאנחנו שמים על ערוצים ואפשר לראות שהן מאוד
אנלוגיות לדרישות שיש לנו לפעולות גם בניסוח המפושט של מידע קוונטי וגם בניסוח הסטנדרטי
של מידע קלאסי. בניסוח המפושט של מידע קוונטי פעולות מיוצגות על ידי מטריצות יוניטריות כי הן
מתאימות בדיוק להעתקות הלינאריות שתמיד ממירות וקטורי מצב קוונטיים לוקטורי מצב קוונטיים עבור
מערכת נתונה. ובאופן דומה פעולות הסתברותיות מיוצגות על ידי מטריצות סטוכסטיות כי אלו הן אלו ש
תמיד ממירות וקטורי הסתברות לוקטורי הסתברות. כאן אנחנו עובדים עם מטריצות צפיפות ויש
את הדרישה הנוספת הזו לגבי מערכות מורכבות שמתברר שאינה הכרחית עבור וקטורי מצב קוונטיים
או וקטורי הסתברות, אבל מלבד זאת הדרישות אנלוגיות ובמובן מסוים נכפות עלינו על ידי הבחירה
לייצג מצבים קוונטיים באמצעות מטריצות צפיפות. הנה כמה פרטים נוספים על ערוצים כולל מוסכמה
לגבי איך נחשוב על מערכות הקלט והפלט של ערוץ לאורך השיעור, וגם עוד פירוט
על הדרישה שערוצים תמיד ממירים מטריצות צפיפות למטריצות צפיפות. ראשית, לכל ערוץ יש
מערכת קלט ומערכת פלט. אפשר לתת שמות למערכות האלה איך שנרצה, אבל לאורך
השיעור אני אשתמש בשם X להתייחס למערכת הקלט ובשם Y להתייחס למערכת הפלט. מבחינה מושגית הערוץ
ממיר את מערכת הקלט למערכת הפלט, כך שמערכות הקלט והפלט אף פעם לא מתקיימות בו-זמנית.
מתחילים עם X, הערוץ מופעל או מבוצע, והתוצאה היא ש-X הומר ל-Y שמצבו
נקבע על ידי ההעתקה הלינארית המשויכת לערוץ. מערכות הקלט והפלט של ערוץ לא חייבות להיות זהות ובפרט
לא חייבות להיות בעלות אותו מספר מצבים קלאסיים. אבל ייתכן שמערכות הקלט והפלט הן למעשה אותה מערכת, או במילים
אחרות X שווה ל-Y, ובמקרה כזה אנחנו פשוט מדמיינים שפי משנה את מצב המערכת, ואכן זה
מאוד לעיתים קרובות המצב שמעניין אותנו. אבל האפשרות הזו עקבית עם הנקודה הראשונה במובן שאף פעם לא
מערכות הקלט והפלט קיימות כשתי מערכות נפרדות באותו זמן, ובכל מקרה זה יהיה נוח לצורכי
השיעור הזה להשתמש באותיות שונות כלומר X ו-Y להתייחס למערכות הקלט והפלט
רק כדי לעזור לנו לשמור על סדר. עכשיו בואו ניכנס קצת יותר לעומק לגבי הדרישה שערוצים תמיד ממירים מטריצות צפיפות
למטריצות צפיפות. נניח שאנחנו מכניסים מערכת חדשה Z לתמונה.
נקרא לקבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים של המערכת החדשה הזו גמא. עכשיו דמיינו שאנחנו יוצרים מערכת מורכבת חדשה ZX
שמורכבת מהמערכת החדשה יחד עם מערכת הקלט X של ערוץ פי, ונניח שהמערכת המורכבת הזו
נמצאת במצב שמתואר על ידי מטריצת צפיפות רו. זה יכול להיות מצב קוונטי שרירותי של הזוג הזה, אבל יהיה מצבו
מה שיהיה, תמיד אפשר לבטא את מטריצת הצפיפות רו בצורה שמוצגת על המסך, כאשר גם A וגם B
נעים על פני קבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים גמא וכל רו AB היא מטריצה כלשהי שהשורות והעמודות שלה מתאימות
לקבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים של X, ואנחנו לא צריכים לתת שם לקבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים הזו בשלב הזה. רק להבהיר, כל רו AB היא לא בהכרח
מטריצת צפיפות בפני עצמה, אבל המטריצה השלמה רו היא בהכרח מטריצת צפיפות. כשמפעילים את ערוץ פי על
המערכת X היא הופכת ל-Y ואז נשארים עם הזוג ZY, והדרך שבה קובעים את
מצב הזוג הזה אחרי הפעלת פי רק על X היא להעריך את ההעתקה הלינארית פי על כל אחת מהמטריצות רו AB.
דרך אחרת לומר את זה היא שלוקחים את המכפלה הטנסורית של ההעתקה פי עם העתקת הזהות על מטריצות ריבועיות שהשורות והעמודות שלהן
מתאימות לגמא, וזה בתורו מתאים לעשיית כלום למערכת החדשה Z. אבל זה תיאור שקול
ואין צורך להיכנס לפרטים על מכפלות טנסוריות של העתקות מהסוג הזה. הן
כן עובדות בצורה די ישירה שאנלוגית לאיך שהן עובדות עבור וקטורים ומטריצות. דרך אחת לחשוב על זה ויזואלית היא
במונחים של מטריצות בלוקים, ואם נעשה את ההנחה המפשטת שקבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים גמא מורכבת מ
המספרים השלמים בין 0 ל-N מינוס אחד עבור מספר שלם חיובי M כלשהו, אז זה נהיה קל לכתוב את כל זה כפי ש
מוצג ממש כאן. ועכשיו, לחזור על הדרישה שאנחנו שמים על פי כדי שיהיה ערוץ תקף, אנחנו חייבים תמיד לקבל מטריצת
צפיפות מהתהליך הזה, וזה חייב להיות נכון ללא קשר לבחירה שנעשה עבור המערכת Z וגם ל
בחירה שנעשה עבור רו בתנאי שהיא מטריצת צפיפות. זה אולי נשמע כמו דרישה די מחמירה ו
אולי גם נראה שמאוד קשה לבדוק אותה, אבל כפי שנראה עד סוף השיעור זה בעצם לא כל כך מחמיר
או קשה לבדיקה, ובפרט יש לנו אפיונים מתמטיים נחמדים לתנאי הזה
שקשורים לייצוגים השונים שנדבר עליהם קצת מאוחר יותר בשיעור. עכשיו בואו נסתכל על כמה דוגמאות של ערוצים
ונתחיל עם קטגוריה שלמה של ערוצים שנקראת ערוצים יוניטריים. במילים פשוטות אלו הן פעולות
יוניטריות בדיוק כמו שיש לנו בניסוח המפושט של מידע קוונטי, כשהן נצפות כערוצים. ליתר דיוק, נניח ש-U היא מטריצה יוניטרית
שמייצגת פעולה יוניטרית על מערכת X. אז בניסוח המפושט של מידע קוונטי
היינו מכפילים את המטריצה הזו בוקטור מצב קוונטי נתון כדי לקבוע את הפעולה שיש לאופרציה הזו על אותו מצב קוונטי.
הדרך שזה עובד עבור מטריצות צפיפות היא שמכפילים את מטריצת הצפיפות משמאל ב-U ומימין ב-U
דאגר. במונחים מתמטיים אנחנו מתייחסים לפעולה הזו כצמידות על ידי המטריצה U. זה עקבי עם זה ש-ket psi
bra psi היא מטריצת הצפיפות שמתארת את המצב שמיוצג על ידי וקטור המצב הקוונטי psi, וזה די
קל לבדוק את זה. בפרט אם היינו מפעילים U על וקטור המצב הקוונטי ket psi אז היינו מקבלים U כפול ket psi ו
ייצוג מטריצת הצפיפות שלו ניתן על ידי הוקטור הזה כפול השחלוף הצמוד שלו שזה U כפול ket psi כפול bra psi כפול U
דאגר כשמעריכים את השחלוף הצמוד של U כפול ket psi. אז הדרך שהערוץ הזה מוגדר
הגיונית למצבים טהורים, וכשמשלבים את זה עם לינאריות רואים שזה הגיוני למטריצות צפיפות
באופן כללי, בזכות העובדה שכל מטריצת צפיפות ניתנת לביטוי כצירוף קמור של מצבים טהורים. ההגדרה
הזו תמיד נותנת לנו ערוץ תקף לכל בחירה של פעולה יוניטרית U. בפרט, צמידות על ידי
מטריצה יוניטרית כזו לא משנה את העקבה של מטריצה, ואם מצמידים כל מטריצה חיובית למחצה חד-ערכית
על ידי מטריצה כלשהי נקבל מטריצה חיובית למחצה חד-ערכית אחרת, וזה די קל לקבל את זה
ישירות מההגדרה של מטריצות חיוביות למחצה חד-ערכיות. אז מטריצות צפיפות תמיד ממופות למטריצות
צפיפות, וכל זה נשאר נכון גם אם עושים טנסור של U עם מטריצת הזהות בכל גודל, שזה שקול
להפעלת הערוץ הזה רק על חלק ממערכת מורכבת. הנה דוגמה ממש פשוטה של ערוץ יוניטרי. נניח שלוקחים
את U עצמה להיות מטריצת הזהות. זה מאוד ברור שזה ערוץ תקף שנקרא ערוץ הזהות. לעשות
כלום זה בוודאי פעולה לינארית, ואם מתחילים עם מטריצת צפיפות ולא עושים לה כלום היא
עדיין תהיה מטריצת צפיפות, אז זה ערוץ תקף. אנשים משתמשים בסמלים שונים לציון הערוץ הזה,
לפעמים זה בדיוק אותו סמל שמשתמשים בו למטריצת הזהות, מה שיכול להיות קצת מבלבל אבל בדרך כלל זה לא. כאן אני משתמש ב
אותיות ID קיצור של identity רק כדי למנוע בלבול, והסימון הזה גם הוא די נפוץ. זה אולי נראה כמו
ערוץ מאוד משעמם, אבל בהקשר של העברת מידע זה בעצם ערוץ מושלם שבו
המקבל מקבל בדיוק מה שהשולח שולח, וזה בדרך כלל מה שהכי רוצים בהקשר הזה. דרך נוספת שבה אפשר
לקבל המון דוגמאות של ערוצים היא לקחת צירופים קמורים של ערוצים, או במילים אחרות לממוצע אותם
יחד, והעובדה שאפשר לעשות את זה היא היבט חשוב של ערוצים. כדי להסביר את זה ביתר פירוט נתחיל עם שני ערוצים פי-0 ופי-1 נגיד,
יחד עם מספר ממשי P בין 0 ל-1, ורק להבהיר אנחנו מניחים ששני הערוצים האלה בעלי
אותה מערכת קלט שהיא X וגם אותה מערכת פלט שהיא Y. ועכשיו שקלו מה קורה אם מחליטים
להפעיל את הערוץ הראשון פי-0 בהסתברות P ואחרת, עם ההסתברות הנותרת 1 מינוס P, מפעילים
את הערוץ השני פי-1. למשל אולי בוחרים ביט באקראי עם ההסתברויות האלה ואז משתמשים בביט
האקראי הזה כדי לקבוע איזה ערוץ להפעיל. על ידי כך אנחנו למעשה מפעילים ערוץ חדש שאפשר לקרוא לו פסי
שניתן כצירוף קמור של שני הערוצים שהתחלנו איתם, ושאפשר לבטא כפי שכתוב
על המסך. אפשר תמיד לקחת צירופים לינאריים של העתקות לינאריות כך אגב, והדרך שצירוף
לינארי של העתקות לינאריות מוגדר על קלט נתון היא שפשוט לוקחים את אותו צירוף לינארי של הפלטים.
זה אולי נראה טריוויאלי אבל זה הגיוני. הפלט שמקבלים מהתרחיש ההיפותטי הזה הוא פשוט
הממוצע המשוקלל של הפלטים שהיינו מקבלים משני הערוצים המקוריים. עם זאת זה ערוץ חדש ו
אם פי-0 ופי-1 היו אכן ערוצים תקפים, אז בוודאות ההעתקה החדשה הזו גם תהיה ערוץ תקף. דרך אחרת לומר
את זה במונחים מתמטיים היא שקבוצת כל הערוצים ממערכת קלט נתונה למערכת פלט נתונה היא
קמורה, וזו תכונה מתמטית חשובה של ערוצים. אפשר לעשות את זה באופן כללי יותר. אם יש לנו M ערוצים פי-0 עד פי-M מינוס אחד נגיד,
יחד עם וקטור הסתברות שאומר לנו מה ההסתברות לכל ערוץ, אז מקבלים ערוץ חדש על ידי מיצוע הערוצים בהתאם. אז
במובן מסוים זה מקור אינסופי של ערוצים חדשים. לדוגמה, הסוג שנקרא ערוצים יוניטריים מעורבים הוא מה
שמקבלים כשלוקחים צירופים קמורים של ערוצים יוניטריים. כלומר אם יש לנו M מטריצות יוניטריות U0 עד U M מינוס
אחד, כולן באותו גודל, יחד עם וקטור הסתברות, אז אם לוקחים את הממוצע המשוקלל של הערוצים
המתאימים למטריצות היוניטריות הבודדות כפי שמוצג כאן על המסך, אז נקבל ערוץ. וערוצים
שאפשר לכתוב ככה נקראים ערוצים יוניטריים מעורבים. לא כל ערוץ הוא ערוץ יוניטרי מעורב, אי אפשר לקבל
כל ערוץ בדרך הזו, אבל הם כן עולים לא מעט. עכשיו נסתכל על כמה דוגמאות ספציפיות
של ערוצים. כולן יהיו דוגמאות של ערוצים מ-qubit אחד ל-qubit אחד, שנקראים ערוצי
qubit בקיצור. הראשון נקרא ערוץ איפוס qubit, והרעיון הוא שהערוץ הזה מאפס qubit
למצב אפס. כאן אנחנו משתמשים באות היוונית הגדולה למבדא לציון הערוץ הזה, והדרך שאפשר לזכור מה הערוץ הזה עושה היא
לחשוב על כדור בלוך. למבדא גדולה נראית קצת כמו חץ שמצביע למעלה, ומצב האפס נמצא בראש כדור בלוך, אז כאילו
היא מצביעה למיקום הפלט. הדרך שזה מוגדר במונחים מתמטיים היא שלמבדא של רו שווה לעקבה של רו כפול ket 0 bra 0, אז
אם מעריכים את זה על כל מטריצת צפיפות רו נקבל את מצב האפס כמטריצת צפיפות. טבעי לתהות
למה צריך את העקבה. האם לא היינו יכולים פשוט להגדיר למבדא של רו להיות ket 0 bra 0 בלי העקבה של רו לפני?
והתשובה לשאלה הזו היא לא. ערוצים חייבים להיות העתקות לינאריות וזה לא היה לינארי אם היינו מסירים את העקבה של רו. כמו כן יש לזכור ש
לפעמים צריך לדעת איך ערוץ עובד כהעתקה לינארית על קלטים שאינם מטריצות צפיפות. לדוגמה כפי ש
ראינו קודם, אם רוצים לדעת מה ערוץ עושה כשמפעילים אותו על מערכת מורכבת צריך
להעריך את הערוץ על הבלוקים הבודדים של מטריצת בלוקים גדולה יותר, ולמרות שמטריצת הבלוקים הכוללת עשויה להיות
מטריצת צפיפות, הבלוקים הבודדים בדרך כלל לא יהיו. אז בואו נראה בדיוק מה הערוץ הזה עושה כשמפעילים אותו
רק על חלק אחד של מערכת מורכבת, וליתר דיוק מה הוא עושה כשמפעילים אותו על אחד משני qubit-ים ש
יוצרים ebit. ליתר דיוק נניח ש-A ו-B הם qubit-ים שכזוג נמצאים במצב Bell של phi plus ומפעילים למבדא
על נגיד ה-qubit הראשון A. כדי להבין מה קורה בואו קודם נבטא את מצב phi plus כמטריצת צפיפות, ו
לצורך הדוגמה הזו נשתמש בסימון דירק לעשות את זה. הנה מצב phi plus כוקטור מצב קוונטי, והנה מה שמקבלים כש
מכפילים את הוקטור הזה בשחלוף הצמוד שלו ופורשים הכול. אז אפשר להפעיל את הערוץ על ה-qubit הראשון ולהעריך מה מקבלים. הנה
למבדא מופעלת על ה-qubit הראשון, והנה מה שמקבלים כשמעריכים כל אחד מהאיברים. העקבה של ket 0 bra 0 היא 1
וכך גם העקבה של ket 1 bra 1, אז בשני המקרים האלה הפלט של הערוץ הוא ket 0 bra 0, וזה מסביר
את שני האיברים בתשובה. העקבה של ket 0 bra 1 מצד שני היא אפס, וכך גם העקבה של ket 1 bra 0,
ולכן שני האיברים האלה מתאפסים ולא תורמים כלום לתשובה. עכשיו אפשר לפשט
קצת, ומה שמקבלים זה מצב אפס עבור ה-qubit הראשון שהוא A, ומצב מעורב לחלוטין עבור
ה-qubit השני שהוא B. שימו לב בפרט שלא קיבלנו מצב plus עבור B, מה שלא בהכרח
היה ניחוש רע אם לא היינו יודעים כלום על מטריצות צפיפות והיינו פשוט מסתכלים על ייצוג וקטור המצב הקוונטי של המצב. אבל זה
לא איך שהערוץ הזה עובד ואין שום ערוץ שיכול לעבוד ככה. הערוץ למבדא נקרא ערוץ איפוס qubit, אבל
הדרך שהוא עובד היא יותר כמו לזרוק את ה-qubit הנכנס לפח ולהחליף אותו ב-qubit חדש במצב אפס. אבל זה למעשה
ערוץ ה-qubit היחיד שתמיד פולט את מצב האפס. הנה דוגמה נוספת לערוץ qubit שידוע כ
ערוץ דפאזה מלא. זה מסומן בדלתא, והדרך שהוא עובד היא שהוא משאיר את הרכיבים
האלכסוניים של כל מטריצה 2 על 2 כמו שהם ומאפס את הרכיבים שמחוץ לאלכסון. דלתא היא האות היוונית המקבילה ל-D ב
אלף-בית הלטיני, וזה קיצור של diagonal, אז זו דרך אחת לזכור מה הערוץ הזה עושה. אפשר
לחלופין לבטא את הערוץ הזה בסימון דירק כפי שמוצג על המסך, ורק להבהיר, הפלט
הוא תמיד מטריצה 2 על 2, אז בפרט שני הפלטים של אפס מתייחסים למטריצת 2 על 2 כולה אפסים. לעיתים קרובות אנחנו
עושים את זה וכבר ראינו את זה קודם בסדרה. הסמל אפס משמש בדרך כלל, אולי באופן דו-משמעי, לציון האלמנט
האפס של כל דבר שאנחנו מדברים עליו, בין אם זה סקלרים, וקטורים, מטריצות או כל דבר אחר. בואו נעשה את אותו דבר שעשינו קודם עבור
ערוץ איפוס ה-qubit ונראה מה קורה אם מפעילים את הערוץ הזה על חצי ebit. ההגדרה זהה אז לא אעבור
על החלק הזה, והתוצאה היא המצב המוצג על המסך שהוא בעצם ביט אקראי משותף. אז מה
שהערוץ הזה עשה היה בעצם להמיר ebit לזוג מתואם לחלוטין של ביטים קלאסיים אקראיים,
וזה עקבי עם פרשנות כללית יותר של הערוץ הזה. על ידי איפוס הרכיבים שמחוץ לאלכסון של מטריצת צפיפות אנחנו למעשה
זורקים את הדברים הקוונטיים במטריצת צפיפות ומשאירים מטריצת צפיפות אלכסונית שמייצגת
מצב הסתברותי קלאסי. דרך אחרת לחשוב על זה היא שהערוץ הזה מייצג ערוץ קלאסי מושלם ללא רעש שמשדר ביט.
אז אם שמים מצב אפס או מצב אחד או צירוף קמור של שני המצבים האלה לתוך הערוץ, אז המצב יוצא ללא שינוי. אבל אם מנסים
לשים מצב קוונטי לתוכו כמו מצב plus למשל, זה כאילו הערוץ מודד את המצב עם מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי ואז
משדר את התוצאה הקלאסית. דוגמה אחרונה של ערוץ qubit היא ערוץ הדפולריזציה המלא. מה
שהערוץ הזה עושה הוא תמיד לפלוט את המצב המעורב לחלוטין. אז הוא דומה במובן מסוים לערוץ איפוס
ה-qubit, חוץ מזה שמקבלים מצב מעורב לחלוטין פחות שימושי במקום qubit מאותחל. דרך טבעית
לחשוב על הערוץ הזה היא שהוא מייצג צורה קיצונית של רעש, ובכל מה שנוגע לערוצי qubit
זה באמת לא נהיה יותר רועש מזה. אין לי טריק מנמוני טוב לשתף לזכירת מה זה עושה, מלבד לומר שאומגה היא האות
האחרונה באלף-בית היווני ולפעמים היא מקושרת לסוף כל הדברים, ואולי זה מה שקורה
לכל ה-qubit-ים בסופו של דבר. מבחינת רעש, זה די קיצוני. אבל דבר אחד שכן אפשר לעשות הוא לשקול צירוף קמור
של הערוץ הזה וערוץ הזהות, עם אולי הסתברות קטנה אפסילון לדפולריזציה
מלאה. זו צורה פחות קיצונית של רעש שבה מצב qubit נתון ברוב המקרים יישאר כמו שהוא, אבל יש
סיכוי קטן שהוא יהפוך למעורב לחלוטין. גאומטרית אפשר לחשוב על זה כהתכווצות קלה של כדור בלוך לכיוון המרכז,
ואגב אפשר לעשות משהו דומה עם ערוץ הדפאזה המלא כדי לדגם את תהליך הדקוהרנס למשל, שבו דברים
נהיים קצת יותר קלאסיים דרך תהליך כלשהו. אז אלו שלוש דוגמאות בסיסיות של ערוצי qubit, ו
נחזור אליהן בעיקר כמקור לדוגמאות לאורך שארית השיעור. עכשיו נדון בייצוגים מתמטיים
של ערוצים, ונתחיל בשאלה בסיסית. העתקות לינאריות מוקטורים לוקטורים תמיד אפשר
לייצג באמצעות מטריצות בדרך מוכרת, שהיא שפעולת ההעתקה הלינארית מתוארת על ידי כפל
מטריצה-וקטור. אבל ערוצים הם העתקות לינאריות ממטריצות למטריצות, לא מוקטורים לוקטורים, אז
באופן כללי איך אפשר לבטא ערוצים במונחים מתמטיים? לפעמים לערוצים מיוחדים תהיה לנו נוסחה פשוטה
שמתארת אותם, וזה היה המקרה בדוגמאות של ערוצי qubit שכבר דנו בהם. אבל זה לא
מעשי באופן כללי כי לא תמיד תהיה נוסחה כל כך נחמדה. כנקודת השוואה, בניסוח
המפושט של מידע קוונטי אנחנו משתמשים במטריצות יוניטריות כדי לייצג פעולות על וקטורי מצב קוונטיים.
כל מטריצה יוניטרית מייצגת פעולה תקפה וכל פעולה תקפה ניתנת לביטוי כמטריצה יוניטרית. אז
בעצם מה שהשאלה הזו שואלת הוא איך עושים את זה עבור ערוצים, והתשובה לשאלה הזו היא שיש למעשה מספר דרכים לייצג
ערוצים במונחים מתמטיים. בפרט נדון בשלוש דרכים שונות לייצוג ערוצים ש
נקראות על שם שלושה אנשים שעבודתם מילאה תפקיד חשוב בפיתוחם: Stinespring, Kraus ו-Choi.
קודם נראה איך הייצוגים השונים האלה עובדים, ואז בחלק האחרון של השיעור נראה איך שלושת הייצוגים קשורים וב
פרט איך אפשר להמיר ביניהם. נראה גם שהייצוגים האלה לוכדים בדיוק את הדרישות שיש לנו מערוצים,
כלומר שהם העתקות לינאריות ושהם תמיד ממירים מטריצות צפיפות למטריצות צפיפות גם כש
מפעילים אותם רק על חלק ממערכת מורכבת. ראשון הוא ייצוג Stinespring. W. Forrest Stinespring
היה מתמטיקאי שלא עבד על מידע קוונטי, וייצוגי Stinespring כפי שאתאר
אותם הם במובן מסוים רק נגזרת מעבודתו בתורת האופרטורים בשנות ה-50. אבל העבודה הזו הייתה בוודאי
חלק חשוב בפיתוח המתמטיקה שערוצים קוונטיים מבוססים עליה. הרעיון מאחורי הדרך הזו לייצג ערוצים הוא שכל
ערוץ ניתן למימוש בדרך מסוימת שאתאר עכשיו. קודם יוצרים מערכת מורכבת שמורכבת מ
הקלט של הערוץ שאנחנו מממשים, יחד עם מערכת עבודה מאותחלת. אז
מבצעים פעולה יוניטרית על המערכת המורכבת, ולבסוף כל חלק מהמערכת המורכבת שנוצרת
שמתאים לפלט של הערוץ נשאר כמו שהוא או מוצא כפלט, והשאר נזרק או מועבר דרך עקבה חלקית. זה מועיל
לבטא את זה בצורת דיאגרמה, והכי פשוט להתחיל עם המקרה המיוחד שבו מערכות הקלט
והפלט זהות. הדיאגרמה הזו אגב היא בדיוק כמו דיאגרמת circuit קוונטי, חוץ מזה שהחוטים
מייצגים מערכות שרירותיות ולא בהכרח qubit-ים בודדים. אז מתחילים עם מערכת הקלט X שנמצאת ב
מצב רו, מכניסים מערכת עבודה מאותחלת W, ובדיאגרמה הזו אני מניח שאפס הוא מצב
קלאסי של W ולוקחים את ket 0 כמצב המאותחל של המערכת. אבל אפשר לחלופין לקבע כל מצב טהור
של W ולראות אותו כמצב המאותחל. אז מבצעים פעולה יוניטרית על הזוג WX ואז
עושים עקבה חלקית למערכת העבודה ומוציאים את X כפלט. כאן בדיאגרמה אגב אני משתמש בסמל הארקה מ
הנדסת חשמל כדי לציין ש-W נזרקת. זה לא בהכרח מוסכמה מקובלת ולא תמצאו
את הסמל הזה ב-Qiskit. שם פשוט מתעלמים מה-qubit-ים שלא מעניינים. העניין הוא שאני רק רוצה שיהיה סמל שמבהיר
שאנחנו זורקים את המערכת לצורכי הדיון הזה. באופן כללי לא בהכרח צריך שמערכות
הקלט והפלט יהיו זהות, אז יכולה להיות למשל מערכת פלט Y יחד עם מערכת
זבל G שעוברת עקבה חלקית. כדי ש-U תהיה יוניטרית היא חייבת להיות מטריצה ריבועית, אז יש הנחה
כאן שלזוג GY יחד יש אותו מספר מצבים קלאסיים כמו לזוג WX. לדוגמה אולי המערכות
מורכבות מ-qubit-ים ומערכת הקלט X מורכבת מ-5 qubit-ים ו-W מורכבת מ-10 qubit-ים נגיד, אז U היא פעולה
יוניטרית על 15 qubit-ים. אז ייתכן ש-Y מורכבת מ-4 qubit-ים בלבד, מה שאומר ש-G מורכבת מ-11 qubit-ים,
או אולי אלה לא qubit-ים בכלל. מה שחשוב הוא ש-WX ביחד ו-GY ביחד בעלי אותו מספר של
מצבים קלאסיים כך ש-U יכולה להיות יוניטרית. תיאור של ערוץ כזה נקרא ייצוג Stinespring של הערוץ. עכשיו זה
די פשוט לטעון שכל העתקה פי שניתנת לתיאור בדרך הזו היא למעשה ערוץ תקף. ב
פרט אם מתחילים עם מטריצת צפיפות ואז מוסיפים מערכת עבודה נוספת, אז בוודאות
נישאר עם מטריצת צפיפות. כבר ציינו שהפעלת פעולה יוניטרית נותנת לנו ערוץ תקף, ו
אם יש לנו מטריצת צפיפות של מערכת מורכבת ועושים עקבה חלקית לאחת מהמערכות, אז שוב נישאר עם מטריצת צפיפות. אז כשמרכיבים
את הצעדים האלה מובטח שזה תמיד ימיר מטריצות צפיפות למטריצות צפיפות, וזה גם לינארי.
מה שבכלל לא ברור בשלב הזה הוא שכל ערוץ אכן ניתן למימוש בדרך הזו עבור בחירה כלשהי
של מערכת העבודה ומערכת הזבל וכמובן הפעולה היוניטרית U. אבל זה נכון ו
נראה למה עד סוף השיעור. הנה דוגמה לייצוג Stinespring עבור ערוץ הדפאזה
המלא של qubit. ולהבהיר, עכשיו החוטים הם qubit-ים וזהו gate controlled-NOT
רגיל. זה מאוד פשוט. ה-qubit הנכנס נמצא למעלה והכנסנו qubit עבודה מאותחל למצב
אפס. אז מבצעים פעולת controlled-NOT כאשר ה-qubit הנכנס הוא הבקרה וה-qubit של
מרחב העבודה הוא המטרה, ואז ה-qubit של מרחב העבודה עובר עקבה חלקית. באופן אינטואיטיבי הגיוני
שזה צריך לממש את ערוץ הדפאזה המלא כי ה-controlled-NOT פועל כמעין מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי על ה-qubit
העליון על ידי העתקת המצב הקלאסי שלו ל-qubit התחתון, ואז התוצאה נזרקת.
אבל אפשר גם לעבור על חישוב, וכמובן שזה רעיון טוב לעשות את זה כי אנחנו באמת
לא צריכים לסמוך יותר מדי על האינטואיציה שלנו. אפשר להתחיל בלרשום את ייצוג מטריצת הצפיפות של
שני ה-qubit-ים אחרי שה-qubit של מרחב העבודה הוכנס, ושימו לב שאנחנו משתמשים במוסכמת סדר ה-qubit-ים כרגיל
כאשר ה-qubit התחתון הוא השמאלי וה-qubit העליון הוא מימין. אפשר לבטא את מטריצת הצפיפות הזו
באופן מפורש כמטריצה 4 על 4 ממשית כפי שמוצג על המסך, ואז מחשבים את ההשפעה
שיש ל-gate ה-controlled-NOT על מטריצת הצפיפות הזו. אז מצמידים באמצעות המטריצה היוניטרית המשויכת ל-gate
הזה, שוב תוך שמירה על מוסכמת סדר ה-qubit-ים. אז זו המטריצה היוניטרית
הנכונה, והתוצאה מוצגת כאן. למעשה ה-gate controlled-NOT
שינה סדר של הרכיבים של המטריצה המקורית שלנו קצת, כך שעכשיו הרכיבים שאולי אינם אפס נמצאים ב
ארבע הפינות. נשאר לחשב את העקבה החלקית, ואפשר לעשות את זה ישירות מהמטריצה, אבל
חלופה היא להמיר לסימון דירק כפי שמוצג על המסך, ואז זה נהיה די קל להעריך
מה קורה כשעושים עקבה חלקית ל-qubit השמאלי בתוך כל איבר, והתוצאה היא שרק
האיברים המתאימים לרכיבים האלכסוניים של רו שורדים, ולכן דפאזנו את ה-qubit כ
צפוי. כמו תמיד, בדקו את זה בעצמכם בקצב שלכם אם תבחרו לעשות את זה. זו דוגמה טובה
לקבל קצת תרגול בעבודה עם מטריצות צפיפות ועם עקבות
חלקיות. זו לא הדרך היחידה לממש את ערוץ הדפאזה המלא. הנה ייצוג Stinespring חלופי עבור הערוץ
הזה. לא אעבור על החישוב בפירוט בסרטון הזה, אבל אראה אותו בקצרה למקרה שתרצו לעצור את הסרטון ולהסתכל
מקרוב. הדרך שזה עובד דומה לראשון אבל הפרטים
שונים. הפעם מתחילים עם gate Hadamard על ה-qubit של מרחב העבודה שמכניס אותו למצב plus, ואם
פורשים את המכפלה הטנסורית מקבלים את המטריצה שמוצגת על המסך. כדי להפעיל את ה-gate controlled-Z
מצמידים באמצעות המטריצה היוניטרית המשויכת, והתוצאה של זה היא להכניס כמה סימני מינוס ל
מטריצה. בפרט, השורה האחרונה והעמודה האחרונה שתיהן מוכפלות במינוס 1.
והפעם זה היה מאוד מבולגן להמיר לסימון דירק, אז נחשב את העקבה החלקית
ישירות. כשעושים עקבה חלקית ל-qubit הראשון מתוך שניים, מה שמקבלים בסוף הוא הסכום של שני הבלוקים האלכסוניים 2 על 2,
והתוצאה הסופית היא שוב שדפאזנו את ה-qubit. זה היה מהיר, ואם אתם לא
רגילים לחישובים מהסוג הזה אז קחו את הזמן שלכם ועשו את זה לאט. מהירות לא חשובה
כאן. לסיום הדוגמה הזו אציין שיש רעיון די פשוט מאחורי המימוש הזה שמבוטא
די יפה על ידי הצעד האחרון של החישוב שרק עברנו עליו בקצרה. דרך תמציתית יותר לומר את זה
היא שאם ממצעים מטריצת צפיפות qubit נתונה עם אותה מטריצת צפיפות מצומדת על ידי מטריצת Pauli Z, אז
זה אותו דבר כמו דפאזה. אז ערוץ הדפאזה המלא הוא במקרה ערוץ יוניטרי
מעורב שבו או לא עושים כלום, כלומר מבצעים את פעולת הזהות, או מבצעים gate Z, כל אחד
עם הסתברות חצי. טוב לדעת. אז לסיכום, יש לנו שני ייצוגי
Stinespring שונים של ערוץ הדפאזה המלא, וזה אומר לנו משהו חשוב, שייצוגי Stinespring הם
לא יחידאיים, ולמעשה יש אינסוף כאלה לכל ערוץ נתון. עכשיו נדון בייצוגי Kraus
של ערוצים, שנותנים לנו דרך נוחה ופורמולאית לבטא ערוצים דרך כפל
וחיבור מטריצות. ייצוגי Kraus נקראים על שם Karl Kraus שהיה פיזיקאי שבין
היתר עבד על הרבה מהפרטים המתמטיים הבסיסיים של ערוצים והניסוח הכללי של מידע קוונטי באופן רחב יותר. באופן כללי ייצוג
Kraus הוא ביטוי של ערוץ בצורה שמוצגת כאן על המסך. בפרט יש לנו
אוסף של מטריצות שכאן נקראות A0 עד A N מינוס 1 עבור מספר שלם חיובי N כלשהו, והן מציינות את
פעולת הערוץ על כל קלט נתון רו לפי הנוסחה. בקיצור, מצמידים את רו על ידי כל אחת מהמטריצות האלה
שלעיתים קרובות מכונות מטריצות Kraus בהקשר הזה, ואז סוכמים את התוצאה, וזה נותן לנו את הפלט. לכל המטריצות האלה חייבות להיות
אותן ממדים, וספציפית העמודות שלהן חייבות להתאים למצבים הקלאסיים של מערכת הקלט ו
השורות חייבות להתאים למצבים הקלאסיים של מערכת הפלט. אם זה המצב אז כשלוקחים את המכפלה AK כפול רו כפול AK דאגר לכל
בחירה של K, מקבלים מטריצה ריבועית שהשורות והעמודות שלה מתאימות למצבים הקלאסיים של מערכת הפלט,
ואז הגיוני שהביטוי מייצר מטריצת צפיפות של מערכת הפלט. עכשיו, זה לא המצב
שלבחירה שרירותית של מטריצות Kraus אלה מקבלים ערוץ תקף. אבל יש תנאי די פשוט
על המטריצות שמבטיח שנקבל ערוץ תקף, והתנאי הזה הוא הנוסחה המוצגת ממש כאן.
ספציפית, אם סוכמים את המכפלה של AK דאגר כפול AK על כל ערכי K
אז חייבים לקבל את מטריצת הזהות, וזו תהיה מטריצת הזהות שהשורות והעמודות שלה מתאימות ל
מצבים הקלאסיים של מערכת הקלט. אז התנאי הזה חייב להתקיים כדי שההעתקה שמוגדרת על ידי
המשוואה הראשונה תהיה ערוץ תקף, ומתברר שלכל ערוץ אכן יש ייצוג שלוקח
את הצורה הזו כל עוד לוקחים N להיות גדול מספיק. הנה כמה דוגמאות של ייצוגי Kraus
ונתחיל עם ערוץ איפוס ה-qubit. אפשר לקבל ייצוג Kraus עבור הערוץ הזה על ידי שימוש ב
שתי מטריצות Kraus: ket 0 bra 0 ו-ket 0 bra 1, אז N שווה ל-2 בדוגמה הזו.
אפשר להציב את הבחירות האלה בנוסחה הכללית ויש לנו רק שני איברים אז קל לרשום את הסכום,
ואם מפשטים ומזהים שהביטוי בסוגריים הוא העקבה של רו אז רואים שמקבלים
את ערוץ איפוס ה-qubit. אפשר גם לבדוק שהתנאי הנדרש על המטריצות האלה מתקיים, וזה עניין פשוט של הצבת מטריצות
Kraus במשוואה והערכה, ומקבלים את מטריצת הזהות כנדרש. לדוגמה נוספת, בואו שוב נסתכל על
ערוץ הדפאזה המלא. לקיחת המטריצות ket 0 bra 0 ו-ket 1 bra 1 עובדת, וזה אפשר לבדוק על ידי
פריסת הסכום ולראות די ישירות שמקבלים מה שצריך. ושוב התנאי הנדרש מתקיים.
חלופה היא לקחת A0 להיות מטריצת הזהות חלקי שורש 2 ו-A1 להיות
סיגמא Z חלקי שורש 2, ואם מעריכים רואים שוב שמקבלים את ערוץ הדפאזה המלא בהתבסס על התצפית
שעשינו על הערוץ הזה קצת קודם בשיעור, ושוב התנאי הנדרש די פשוט
לבדיקה. כתרגיל לעבור עליו אם תמצאו את זה מועיל, שקלו את ערוץ הדפולריזציה
המלא שפולט את המצב המעורב לחלוטין עבור כל קלט של מטריצת צפיפות. עבור זה נדרשות ארבע מטריצות Kraus.
לא ניתן למצוא ייצוג Kraus כאשר N הוא שלוש או פחות. הנה בחירה אחת שעובדת ו
הנה אחרת. אז התרגיל הוא לוודא שהבחירות האלה עובדות וגם לבדוק שהתנאי הנדרש
מתקיים. שווה לציין שהחלופה השנייה בעצם אומרת שאפשר לדפולריזיז לחלוטין qubit, או במילים אחרות
לאקרר אותו לחלוטין, על ידי בחירה אקראית של אחת מארבע מטריצות Pauli כולל הזהות והפעלת
הפעולה היוניטרית המתאימה על ה-qubit. ואז ערוץ הדפולריזציה המלא הוא דוגמה נוספת של ערוץ
יוניטרי מעורב. האחרון מבין שלושת ייצוגי הערוצים שנכסה הוא ייצוג Choi. Man-Duen Choi
הוא מתמטיקאי שעובד בתורת המטריצות ובנושאים אחרים, וייצוג Choi נקרא על שמו
על בסיס מאמר ממש אלגנטי שפרסם ב-1975 שבמובן מסוים קושר את הכול יחד. ייצוג
Choi של ערוץ פי הוא מטריצה בודדת שמסומנת באופן מקובל J של פי, וספציפית אם ל
מערכת הקלט יש N מצבים קלאסיים ולמערכת הפלט יש M מצבים קלאסיים, אז ייצוג Choi של פי יהיה
מטריצה ריבועית NM על NM. לפני שאספר לכם בדיוק איך המטריצה מוגדרת, אני רוצה להזכיר כמה מ
התכונות המפתח שלה שמניעות את הייצוג בצורה שההגדרה עצמה אולי לא עושה, לפחות על
פני השטח. ראשית, בניגוד גם לייצוגי Stinespring וגם לייצוגי Kraus, ייצוג Choi
הוא מה שנקרא ייצוג נאמן, מה שאומר שלכל ערוץ יש רק אחד כזה. וזה די חשוב
כי זה אומר ששני ערוצים זהים אם ורק אם ייצוגי ה-Choi שלהם זהים. אז אם
יש לכם שני תיאורים שונים של ערוצים, כמו שני ייצוגי Stinespring שונים או שני ייצוגי Kraus שונים או אולי אחד מ
כל אחד, ואתם רוצים לדעת אם הם בעצם אותו ערוץ, אפשר פשוט לחשב את ייצוג Choi ו
לבדוק אם הם שווים. התכונה השנייה היא שיש תנאים פשוטים לבדיקה על ייצוג Choi שמתקיימים אם ורק
אם יש לנו ערוץ תקף. התכונה הזו לא כל כך מיוחדת, אפשר להגיד את אותו דבר על שני הייצוגים האחרים, אבל זו תכונה טובה
שיש בכל זאת ונדון בה עוד בפירוט בקרוב. עוד דבר שצריך לציין לגבי ייצוג Choi הוא שלמרות שאנחנו
מייצגים ערוץ על ידי מטריצה, המטריצה הזו לא מייצגת ישירות את הערוץ כהעתקה לינארית. למעשה זה
יותר טבעי לשייך את ייצוג Choi למטריצת צפיפות שמייצגת מצב מסוים
מאשר לחשוב על ייצוג Choi כמתאר העתקה לינארית. אבל כן אפשר לשחזר את פעולת הערוץ מ
ייצוג ה-Choi שלו באמצעות נוסחה די פשוטה, אבל זה לא פשוט כמו כפל מטריצות
רגיל. מספיק הקדמות, בואו ניגש להגדרה עצמה. נניח שיש לנו ערוץ פי ממערכת X למערכת Y,
ונניח שקבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים של מערכת הקלט X היא סיגמא. לא נצטרך להתייחס לקבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים של מערכת הפלט אז
להגדרה אין צורך לתת שם לקבוצה הזו. ייצוג Choi של פי מוגדר אז על ידי הביטוי
שמוצג כאן על המסך. יש לנו סכום שנע על כל המצבים הקלאסיים A ו-B של מערכת הקלט ואנחנו
סוכמים ket A bra B טנסור הערוץ פי מופעל על ket A bra B. אז הייצוג
הזה מוגדר על ידי נוסחה, ויש כמה דרכים שונות שאפשר לחשוב על הנוסחה הזו. לפני שאדון בהן אני רוצה
להזכיר שלפעמים ייצוג Choi מוגדר בצורה קצת שונה שבה הסדר של שני גורמי הטנסור הפוך, כלומר
שפי של ket A bra B מופיע כגורם הטנסור הראשון ולא השני. אבל שתי הדרכים לעשות את זה
שקולות עד כדי סימטריה פשוטה זו, אבל מה שזה אומר הוא שכשמשתמשים בייצוג הזה כדאי
להבהיר באיזה סדר משתמשים. הסדר הזה הוא הדרך שזה נעשה ב-Qiskit וזה גם טוב יותר ל
תיאור הייצוג ויזואלית במונחים של מטריצות בלוקים, אז זה מה שנלך איתו. ליתר דיוק לגבי תיאור מטריצת
הבלוקים, אם מניחים שקבוצת המצבים הקלאסיים סיגמא מורכבת מהמספרים השלמים מאפס עד N מינוס 1
עבור מספר שלם חיובי N כלשהו, אז אפשר לחלופין לכתוב J של פי כמטריצת בלוקים כפי שמוצג ממש כאן על
המסך. במילים אחרות ייצוג Choi של פי הוא המטריצה שמקבלים כשמעריכים פי על כל אחת מ
מטריצות הקלט שיש להן בדיוק רכיב אחד ששווה ל-1 וכל שאר הרכיבים אפס, ואז מסדרים אותן
למטריצה בצורה די טבעית. אולי לא ברור מראש למה היינו רוצים ליצור מטריצה כזו, אבל
זה כן מתברר כמאוד שימושי. דבר אחד שצריך לשים לב אליו הוא שהקבוצה שמכילה את המטריצות ket A bra B כאשר
A וגם B נעים על כל המספרים השלמים מ-0 עד N מינוס 1 יוצרת בסיס למרחב של כל המטריצות N על N. אז אם
יש לכם את המטריצה הזו אז בוודאות אפשר לקבוע מה פי עושה למטריצה שרירותית N על N על ידי לינאריות,
ספציפית על ידי לקיחת צירופים לינאריים מתאימים של הבלוקים. אז המטריצה J של פי אכן קובעת באופן יחיד
את פי כהעתקה לינארית. דרך נוספת לחשוב על ייצוג Choi של ערוץ היא
שהוא מייצג מצב כמטריצת צפיפות כשהוא מנורמל, ספציפית על ידי חלוקה במספר
המצבים הקלאסיים של מערכת הקלט, שאמשיך לסמן ב-N קטנה. זה תמיד ייתן לנו
מטריצת צפיפות שלעיתים קרובות מכונה מצב Choi של הערוץ. הנה איך זה עובד ביתר פירוט.
דמיינו קודם שיש לנו שני עותקים זהים של מערכת הקלט ונשקול את וקטור המצב הקוונטי psi
שמוצג על המסך שמייצג מצב שזור מקסימלית של הזוג הזה של מערכות זהות. ל
דוגמה אם סיגמא היא האלף-בית הבינארי אז זהו מצב phi plus, אבל אפשר לחשוב על מצב מוגדר באופן אנלוגי עבור
כל בחירה של סיגמא, ומה שמקבלים הוא מצב מאוד שזור ולמעשה הוא שזור ככל שאפשר
בהינתן בחירת המערכות. כדי לקבל את ייצוג מטריצת הצפיפות של המצב מכפילים את וקטור המצב בשחלוף הצמוד שלו כרגיל, ו
ככה זה נראה. ולבסוף אם חושבים על ייצוג Choi של הערוץ חלקי N, אז רואים שזה המצב ש
היינו מקבלים אם היינו מפעילים את הערוץ פי על המערכת השנייה. בצורת דיאגרמה הנה
איך זה נראה. יש לנו שני עותקים של המערכת X במצב השזור המקסימלי psi. הערוץ פי
מופעל על המערכת השנייה שהיא זו למעלה בדיאגרמה, והמצב שמתקבל הוא מצב Choi של פי. כמובן שבדרך כלל לא
היינו נותנים את אותו שם לשתי מערכות שונות כאלה. בדרך כלל לא מועיל לתת את אותו שם לשני דברים שונים, אבל זה כן הגיוני
במקרה הזה רק כדי ליצור את הקשר עם ייצוגי Choi. יש כמה מסקנות שאפשר להסיק מיד מהדרך הזו של
הסתכלות על ייצוגי Choi. אחת היא שבגלל שמצב Choi הוא מטריצת צפיפות, בהנחה שפי הוא
ערוץ תקף, אנחנו מסיקים שייצוג Choi של פי חייב להיות חיובי למחצה חד-ערכי. זכרו שזו
דרישה שאנחנו שמים על ערוצים שהם תמיד ממירים מטריצות צפיפות למטריצות צפיפות, וזה
רק מקרה מיוחד אחד של זה. המסקנה השנייה היא שאם לוקחים את מצב Choi של כל ערוץ פי ו
אז זורקים את מערכת הפלט Y, אז חייבים להישאר עם המצב המעורב לחלוטין של מערכת הקלט X. זה
בגלל שהפעלת ערוץ על מערכת ואז זריקת המערכת שנוצרת לפח שקולה לפשוט לזרוק את המערכת המקורית ל
פח, ואם היינו עושים את זה עם המצב השזור המקסימלי שלנו, מטריצת הצפיפות שהיינו נשארים איתה
הייתה מטריצת הזהות חלקי N, או במילים אחרות המצב המעורב לחלוטין של מערכת X. הרעיון במונחים
מתמטיים יותר הוא שהרכבת כל ערוץ עם העקבה על מערכת הפלט חייבת להיות שווה לעקבה על
מערכת הקלט, וזה בגלל שערוצים חייבים לשמר עקבה מתוקף העובדה שהם העתקות לינאריות ש
תמיד ממירות מטריצות צפיפות למטריצות צפיפות. ברגע שיש לנו את המשוואה הזו אפשר לנקות את המכנה N
משני הצדדים כדי לקבל תנאי קצת יותר נקי. במילים, ביצוע עקבה חלקית על מערכת הפלט
של ייצוג Choi של ערוץ חייב לתת לנו את מטריצת הזהות על מערכת הקלט. אז לסיכום ייצוגי
Choi של ערוצים הם תמיד חיוביים למחצה חד-ערכיים, ואם עושים עקבה חלקית למערכת הפלט בהכרח
נשארים עם מטריצת הזהות על מערכת הקלט. כפי שמתברר, אלו לא רק תנאים הכרחיים אלא
גם מספיקים, כלומר אם פי היא העתקה לינארית שרירותית כלשהי ושני התנאים האלה מתקיימים,
אז זה חייב להיות שפי הוא למעשה ערוץ תקף, ונראה למה זה כך עד סוף השיעור.
בואו נסתכל על כמה דוגמאות ונתחיל עם ערוץ הדפאזה המלא. כדי לחשב את ייצוג Choi זה רק עניין של
הערכת הנוסחה. ערוץ הדפאזה המלא משאיר את ket A bra B כמו שהוא כאשר A שווה ל-B ואחרת הפלט
הוא אפס. אז האיברים בסכום ששורדים הם אלה כאשר A שווה ל-B, והתוצאה מבוטאת על
המסך בסימון דירק. אפשר גם לראות את זה כמטריצת בלוקים. דלתא משאיר רכיבים אלכסוניים ומאפס רכיבים מחוץ
לאלכסון, ואז נשארים עם מטריצה שיש בה אחדות בפינה השמאלית העליונה ובפינה הימנית התחתונה כאשר כל
שאר הרכיבים הם אפס, וזה עקבי עם הביטוי הראשון. לדוגמה נוספת בואו נשקול את ערוץ הדפולריזציה המלא. שוב
אפשר להתחיל בלרשום את הנוסחה, ובדיוק כמו בדוגמה הקודמת לא מקבלים תרומה לסכום
כאשר A לא שווה ל-B, והפעם כאשר A שווה ל-B מקבלים את המצב המעורב לחלוטין, ואפשר לפשט את זה ל
חצי כפול מטריצת הזהות 2 על 2 בטנסור עם עצמה, שזה חצי כפול מטריצת הזהות
4 על 4. אפשר גם לחשוב על זה במונחים של מטריצות בלוקים וטבעי שמקבלים את אותה תוצאה. וכ
דוגמה אחרונה נשקול את ערוץ הזהות עבור qubit בודד. זה קל. הנה הנוסחה ו
כמובן ערוץ הזהות לא עושה כלום, ואפשר לחשוב על התוצאה כפעמיים מטריצת הצפיפות המשויכת למצב phi plus, וזה
עקבי עם מה שמצפים כשחושבים על מצב Choi של הערוץ הזה. והנה זה כמטריצת בלוקים. שימו לב בפרט שייצוג
Choi של ערוץ הזהות הוא לא מטריצת הזהות. זו המטריצה הזו. עכשיו ראינו שלוש דרכים שונות
לייצג ערוצים במונחים מתמטיים, כלומר ייצוגי Stinespring, ייצוגי Kraus וייצוגי
Choi. ויש לנו גם את ההגדרה של ערוץ שהיא שערוץ הוא העתקה לינארית שתמיד
ממירה מטריצות צפיפות למטריצות צפיפות גם כשהערוץ מופעל רק על חלק ממערכת מורכבת. שאלה מאוד טבעית ומאוד חשובה
שצריך לשאול בשלב הזה היא איך יודעים שכל הדברים האלה שקולים. למשל, איך יודעים שכל
העתקה שמתוארת על ידי כל אחד מהייצוגים האלה היא למעשה ערוץ תקף, ואיך יודעים שלא משאירים ערוצים בחוץ?
שארית השיעור מתארת איך אפשר לנמק את כל זה מתמטית. אם אתם מוכנים לקבל את השקילות של הדברים האלה ואתם לא מעוניינים באיך אפשר
לנמק את זה, אז אתם מוזמנים לדלג על שארית הסרטון. אבל אני אישית חושב שהטיעון הוא די
אלגנטי וזו דוגמה טובה לסגנון מסוים של הוכחה מתמטית שעולה מדי פעם בתורת המידע הקוונטי. לא אעבור
על כל הפרטים, חלקם אשאיר לכם, או שתוכלו למצוא אותם בתוכן הכתוב של השיעור הזה שבו הכול כתוב ב
פירוט. אבל אני מקווה להציג תמונה ברורה למדי של איך הכול עובד. מה שאנחנו רוצים לעשות הוא להוכיח את
השקילות של אוסף טענות, והדרך שאפשר לעשות את זה היא להגדיר מעגל של גרירות. בפרט נתחיל
מההגדרה של ערוץ, כלומר העתקה לינארית שתמיד ממירה מטריצות צפיפות למטריצות צפיפות.
מההגדרה הזו אפשר לנמק שייצוג Choi של הערוץ הזה חייב לקיים את שני התנאים ש
כבר דנו בהם, ולמעשה כבר עשינו את זה. זה נדון בהקשר של מצב Choi של ערוץ. אז שוכחים
מההגדרה ועובדים מייצוג Choi, ובהינתן שני התנאים שלנו על ייצוגי Choi אנחנו מסיקים שחייב להתקיים
ייצוג Kraus של ההעתקה פי. אז עושים דבר אנלוגי, שוכחים מייצוגי Choi ועובדים
מייצוג Kraus שרירותי, וממנו אפשר לנמק שחייב להתקיים ייצוג Stinespring עבור ההעתקה פי. ואגב הטיעונים
האלה יהיו מכאניים במובן מסוים, מה שמאפשר לנו בעצם לבצע את ההמרות לפי החצים עבור ערוצים ספציפיים אם נרצה
לעשות את זה. הגרירה האחרונה היא לנמק שאם יש לנו ייצוג Stinespring להעתקה פי אז
ההעתקה הזו חייבת למעשה להיות ערוץ תקף, ושוב כבר עשינו את זה, הפעם בהקשר של ייצוגי
Stinespring. כל ארבע הגרירות האלה ביחד חושפות שארבעת הדברים האלה כולם שקולים, כי אפשר להתחיל מכל אחד מהם ו
לעקוב אחרי הגרירות באופן טרנזיטיבי כדי להגיע לכל אחד מהאחרים. נתחיל עם הגרירה הראשונה
שהיא שאם יש לנו ערוץ פי, כלומר העתקה לינארית שתמיד ממירה מטריצות צפיפות למטריצות צפיפות, אז יש לו ייצוג Choi
שמקיים את שני התנאים שזיהינו קודם, כלומר שהוא חיובי למחצה חד-ערכי
ואם עושים עקבה חלקית למערכת הפלט מקבלים את הזהות על מערכת הקלט. וכפי שציינתי לפני רגע כבר
כיסינו את הגרירה הזו בהקשר של מצבי Choi. בפרט כשמחלקים את ייצוג Choi של ערוץ ב-N, מספר
המצבים הקלאסיים של מערכת הקלט, מקבלים מטריצת צפיפות, ויתר על כן המצב המצומצם של מערכת
הקלט X עבור מצב זה הוא המצב המעורב לחלוטין, או במילים אחרות מטריצת הזהות חלקי N. ניקוי המכנה נותן לנו
את שני התנאים, אז הגרירה הזו די מהירה וקלה כי כבר כיסינו
אותה. עכשיו בואו נסתכל על הגרירה השנייה. הפעם מתחילים עם ייצוג Choi של העתקה ש
אנחנו מניחים שמקיים את שתי הדרישות, והמטרה שלנו היא לבוא עם ייצוג Kraus להעתקה הזו ש
מקיים את הדרישה שדיברנו עליה קודם. הגרירה הזו די מכאנית במובן מסוים. נצטרך
קצת אלגברה לינארית וזה בעיקר יסתכם במניפולציה של מטריצות ווקטורים בצורה
די חכמה. זה מתחיל עם ההנחה שייצוג Choi הוא חיובי למחצה חד-ערכי, שזו הראשונה משתי הדרישות שאנחנו מניחים
שמתקיימות. המושג של מטריצה חיובית למחצה חד-ערכית הוא חשוב מהותית במידע קוונטי ולא רק בהקשר של מטריצות
צפיפות. הוא ממש קריטי כאן. לא היינו יכולים לעשות את זה בלי זה. בפרט ההנחה
ש-J של פי היא חיובית למחצה חד-ערכית מאפשרת לנו לבטא אותה בצורה שמוצגת על המסך עבור בחירה כלשהי של
וקטורים S0 עד S N מינוס 1 ובחירה כלשהי של מספר שלם חיובי N. ואני רוצה לציין במפורש שאלה
לא בהכרח וקטורי יחידה. דרך אחת שבה אפשר להשיג ביטוי כזה היא ממשפט הפירוק הספקטרלי למטריצות חיוביות
למחצה חד-ערכיות שנדון בשיעור הקודם. כאן לא רואים ערכים עצמיים מופיעים במפורש כמו שהיה בפירוק
ספקטרלי, אבל זכרו שערכים עצמיים של מטריצות חיוביות למחצה חד-ערכיות הם תמיד מספרים ממשיים אי-שליליים, וגם יש לזכור שאנחנו
לא דורשים שהוקטורים S0 עד S N מינוס 1 יהיו וקטורי יחידה, אז מה שאפשר לעשות הוא לקחת את השורשים הריבועיים של
הערכים העצמיים ולהכפיל אותם לתוך וקטורי היחידה העצמיים שמקבלים מפירוק ספקטרלי כדי לקבל את
הוקטורים S0 עד S N מינוס 1. למעשה לא חשוב להוכחה הזו שהוקטורים האלה אורתוגונליים. כן
מקבלים את זה מפירוק ספקטרלי, אבל לא נשתמש בזה כאן. ואם היה לנו ביטוי אחר של J של פי כזה שלא הגיע ממשפט
הפירוק הספקטרלי, אז גם זה היה בסדר. עכשיו מפרקים כל אחד מהוקטורים האלה כפי שמוצג על המסך, ו
זה בדיוק כמו שהיינו עושים אם הוקטורים האלה היו וקטורי מצב קוונטיים של זוג מערכות XY ו
היינו מבצעים מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי על מערכת X. להבהיר, אנחנו לא מודדים כלום כאן, אנחנו רק כותבים את הוקטורים האלה בצורה הזו ש
תמיד אפשרית. ועכשיו הנה הטריק: מגדירים מטריצות Kraus A0 עד A N מינוס 1 על ידי חילוץ ה-ket
A מלפני הוקטורים S0 עד S N מינוס 1, הופכים אותם כך שהם נהיים bra A במקום
ket A, ומדביקים אותם בצד ימין כפי שמוצג במשוואה על המסך. דרך אחת לחשוב
על זה היא שבעצם מקפלים את הוקטורים האלה כדי ליצור מטריצות, כך שאם היינו מערמים את העמודות של AK זו על גבי זו
היינו מקבלים בחזרה את SK. אז למטריצות האלה יש בדיוק אותם רכיבים כמו הוקטורים המתאימים, רק
סידרנו את הרכיבים אחרת כדי לקבל מטריצות. אבל אפשר גם לחשוב על המטריצות האלה באופן סימבולי טהור במונחי סימון דירק
כפי שכתוב כאן. ועכשיו בשלב הזה יש שאלה ברורה: למה זה צריך לעבוד? ובכן, בואו לא נתעכב יותר מדי
על למה זה עובד, פשוט נוודא שזה כן עובד. כדי לעשות את זה נגדיר העתקה חדשה שהיא ההעתקה שמוגדרת על ידי
המטריצות האלה כשמתייחסים אליהן כמטריצות Kraus. מה שאפשר לעשות עכשיו הוא לחשב את ייצוג Choi של
ההעתקה החדשה הזו, ונראה שהוא שווה לייצוג Choi של ההעתקה פי שהתחלנו איתה. ו
בגלל שייצוגי Choi הם נאמנים, זה אומר ששתי ההעתקות הן למעשה שוות. לא אעבור על האלגברה בסרטון הזה, תוכלו
לוודא את זה בעצמכם. זה די מכאני ותרגול טוב, וכל מה שצריך לזה נמצא ממש
כאן על המסך. עדיין לא אמרנו כלום על שני התנאים השניים בשתי התיבות, אבל הם
מתבררים כשקולים, ודרך אחת להוכיח את זה היא לוודא את המשוואה שמוצגת כאן בתחתית
המסך. האות T כאן אגב מתייחסת לשחלוף מטריצות, שאפשר לחלופין לחשוב עליו כ
העתקה לינארית שהופכת ket A bra B ל-ket B bra A, וזה רק משהו שצריך כדי שהנוסחה תעבוד. אז
לסיכום, בהחלט יש אלגברה שנדרשת לגרירה הזו, אבל כמו שאמרתי הכול די מכאני,
בעצם ג'ימנסטיקה של אינדקסים כפי שאנשים מסוימים מתייחסים לדבר כזה. אבל אם עוברים על זה ונותנים למוח הזדמנות לעכל, אולי
תצאו עם הבנה טובה יותר של איך ייצוגי Choi וייצוגי Kraus קשורים. הגרירה השלישית מאפשרת לנו
לעבור מייצוג Kraus של העתקה פי כאשר התנאי הרגיל מתקיים, לייצוג Stinespring. זו
דומה ברוחה לגרירה הקודמת במובן שהיא מכאנית ואפשר לראות ולוודא אותה במונחים אלגבריים טהורים.
הרעיון הוא למעשה די פשוט. מה שאפשר לעשות הוא לקחת את מטריצות Kraus שלנו וליצור חלק ממטריצה גדולה יותר על ידי
הערמתן זו על גבי זו כפי שמוצג על המסך. ברגע שמשלימים את זה זה ייתן לנו את המטריצה היוניטרית U עבור
ייצוג Stinespring. מטריצות יוניטריות חייבות להיות מטריצות ריבועיות, אז נצטרך להשלים כמה עמודות נוספות
שצריך לעשות את זה, אבל ממש לא משנה מה הן כל עוד מקבלים מטריצה
יוניטרית. אם רגע שמים בצד את הדאגה ש-U יוניטרית ופשוט מתמקדים בהעתקה הלינארית שמוגדרת על ידי
ייצוג Stinespring שמקבלים מהמטריצה U הזו, אז מה שמגלים הוא שההעתקה שווה ל
העתקה המקורית פי שהוגדרה על ידי ייצוג Kraus שהתחלנו איתו. זה חלק נוסף בהוכחה שלא אעבור עליו בסרטון, תוכלו
למצוא את הפרטים בתוכן הכתוב של השיעור הזה, אבל אולי תרצו להקדיש זמן ולעבור על זה בעצמכם. רק
זכרו כרגיל לסדרה שאנחנו משתמשים במוסכמת סדר qubit-ים לפירוש הדיאגרמה, אז W ו-G
יתאימו לגורמי הטנסור בצד שמאל במשוואות. ואגב, אם כן תעברו
על זה תגלו שבגלל שיש לנו ket 0 bra 0 כגורם הטנסור בצד שמאל במשוואה
שצריך לוודא, החלק היחיד של U שרלוונטי הוא החלק שניתן על ידי מטריצות Kraus. אז כל עוד
משלימים את העמודות של U בצורה שהופכת אותה ליוניטרית, אנחנו בסדר. אבל כמובן שזה דורש שהעמודות שנוצרות מ-A0 עד A N מינוס
1 כשמערמים אותן זו על גבי זו יהיו אורתונורמליות, וזה איפה שהתנאי שאנחנו שמים על ייצוגי Kraus נכנס לפעולה,
ואכן הוא שקול בדיוק לכך שהעמודות אורתונורמליות. הקשרים המתמטיים הרלוונטיים שנדרשים להסקת
המסקנה הזו מוצגים כאן בתחתית המסך, אז עצרו ותוודאו אם תבחרו, או שוב
היעזרו בתוכן הכתוב לפרטים נוספים. בקיצור, מה שקורה כאן גם בגרירה הזו וגם ב
קודמת הוא שאנחנו מתארים את אותן פעולות מתמטיות בדרכים שונות אך שקולות.
הלב הפועם של הכול הוא בעצם כפל מטריצות. הגרירה הרביעית והאחרונה קובעת שאם יש לנו
ייצוג Stinespring להעתקה כלשהי, אז ההעתקה הזו חייבת למעשה להיות ערוץ תקף. וכפי שציינתי
קודם, כבר כיסינו את הגרירה הזו כשדנו בייצוגי Stinespring. לסיכום ובמונחים
קצת שונים, הכנסת מערכת עבודה מאותחלת היא ערוץ תקף. זה בגלל שמכפלה טנסורית של מטריצת
צפיפות קבועה עם מטריצת צפיפות נתונה תמיד נותנת מטריצת צפיפות, וזו העתקה לינארית בזכות הבי-לינאריות
של מכפלות טנסוריות. פעולות יוניטריות הן תמיד ערוצים תקפים כפי שדנתי קודם בשיעור. עקבה חלקית למערכת היא ערוץ תקף כי
העקבה החלקית היא העתקה לינארית שתמיד ממירה מטריצות צפיפות למטריצות צפיפות. ולבסוף הרכבות של
ערוצים הן תמיד ערוצים, מה שדי פשוט אבל בהחלט שווה לציין בפני עצמו. ועם
ארבע הגרירות שכיסינו הוכחנו את השקילות של שלושת ייצוגי הערוצים שלנו יחד עם
ההגדרה המקורית של ערוץ. בפרט התחלנו מההגדרה של ערוץ, ראינו איך ההגדרה גוררת שייצוג
Choi שלו חייב לקיים שני תנאים בסיסיים, אז ראינו איך התנאים האלה מאפשרים למצוא ייצוג Kraus שבתורו
מאפשר למצוא ייצוג Stinespring, ולבסוף ראינו שקיום ייצוג Stinespring חושף שאכן
יש לנו ערוץ תקף. כמובן שיש פרטים טכניים בפנים וזה לא בהכרח פשוט, במיוחד
כשרואים את זה בפעם הראשונה. אבל מה שמעניין וראוי לציון כאן הוא שהגרירות האלה מסודרות בצורה שבאמת
עושה את הדברים קלים ככל האפשר, ובמתמטיקה אף פעם לא צריך להרגיש בושה בלקחת את הדרך הקלה. ל
דוגמה, זה בכלל לא ברור שלכל ערוץ יש ייצוג Stinespring או ייצוג Kraus,
אבל כן יחסית קל להסיק שייצוג Choi של כל ערוץ מקיים את שני התנאים שקישרנו אליו, וזה
מאפשר לנו לעקוב אחרי נתיב יותר או פחות אלגברי לשני הייצוגים האחרים. ברוח דומה
הגרירה האחרונה מייצוג Stinespring בחזרה להגדרה היא גם יחסית ישירה, וזה
מאפשר לנו להסיק שאנחנו מקבלים רק ערוצים ולא העתקות אחרות מייצוגי Choi, בהנחה
שהתנאים הנדרשים מתקיימים. וכפי שרמזתי קודם, הדרך שבה אנחנו מנמקים את הגרירות האלה מספיק מכאנית כדי לאפשר לנו להמיר בקלות
בין הייצוגים, ואם חוזרים לכמה מהדוגמאות שכיסינו קודם בשיעור, תגלו שזה אכן אפשרי
להמיר בין הייצוגים, לפעמים בקלות רבה וישירות. וזהו סוף
השיעור שהיה כולו על ערוצים. דיברנו על מה הם ובדקנו כמה דוגמאות בסיסיות, דנו בשלוש דרכים שבהן ערוצים יכולים
להיות מיוצגים, וצללנו לכמה פרטים טכניים שמוכיחים את השקילות של הייצוגים האלה.
אני מקווה שתצטרפו אלי לשיעור הבא שעוסק כולו במדידות בניסוח הכללי של מידע קוונטי. להתראות עד אז.